so you obviously have to be extremely
mentally tough to be a boxer in your
opinion what are the top three sports
that require the most mental toughness I
say boxing UFC and football I just think
it's a grind it's tough on the body
there's times where you want to just
give up but you got to find something
within your ownself when you're just
alone by yourself you don't have nobody
to pass the ball to nobody to cling to
to help you you can't rely on nobody so
that's why I think boxing UFC are the
toughest sports in the world now
football is challenging because you're
always taking hits that's mentally tough
you know baseball it's mentally tough
but the physical challenge isn't there
so it doesn't really test your true
mental like when your body's breaking
down can you figure it out to me that
that's different there's moments of
suffering but if you don't know
suffering then you're not going to know
the feeling of Joy so that's the thing